we're looking at another question that
involves these ninth roots of unity
surprisingly useful
these things are we're also going to be
using some of our knowledge of
polynomials it's really going to push an
understanding of
roots and intercepts and factors so
let's dive right in
first it says find the ninth roots of
unity now we've
had a look at uh you know being able to
just say off the bat without any other
kind of derivation or working
what the roots of unity are and that's
because we know they have very many
predictable properties for example if we
call the roots of unity
zed you know z1 z2 z3 and so on
we number one know that the first root
of unity is always one
because one is a root of itself but when
we think about the rest of the roots
number one we know there are nine in
total
uh so i'm going to have eight more to
right and secondly i also know that they
are all evenly spaced
around the circumference of the unit
circle just like one is we're going to
start from one
go anti-clockwise around until we you
know run out of ones that we can fit
within the principle argument and then
we'll go the other way around
and do it clockwise so once i start at
one if i go
you know a ninth of the way around the
circle that's a ninth of
two pi radians so therefore i'm going to
write this in exponential form just
because it's the most
concise i can write the next of the
ninth roots of unity
as e to the i two pi on
nine so that's the next one around and
then i'm just going to keep on going
until
i get as far or as close to pi radians
as i can so
the next one over will be 4 pi on 9
then you're going to get 6 pi on 9
[Applause]
the last one that i can fit as i go
around anti-clockwise is 8 pi on 9
because you can see if i added another
2 pi or 9 i would hit 10 pi on 9 which
is a non-principle argument so
as i said before instead of continuing
around anti-clockwise
we're now going to start from 1 which is
an argument of 0 and go clockwise which
will give me
negative arguments so it's going to give
me in order
clockwise i'll get i to the negative 2
pi on 9
i'm going to get e to the i negative 4
pi on 9 and it's really just going to be
the same numbers that i got before just
negative instead of positive so
i can squeeze negative 6 pi 9 just there
and i'll
i reckon i can tuck negative eight pi on
nine
underneath so when you have a look make
sure you got them all
you've got one two three four five six
seven eight
nine nine ninth roots of unity
everything's
great so those are the ninth routes
that's that's all the part a
is asking for but before we dive into
part b
i'm going to do just a little bit of
extra ground work so that
parts b and c will be easier now
normally when i do these solutions i'll
write everything
live but one of the things that is going
to emerge as we go through this working
is that there is a lot
of working to do it's going to be the
main bottleneck it's just going to be
the speed of my writing and
i am a slow writer so what you can see
i've done here is i've got a bit of my
working which i've done beforehand
a bit the vast majority of it and we're
going to use that
to speed through things but i will
explain everything as we go um so if
you're writing along at home just pause
if you want to catch up with all the
writing that i've done
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
sort of write all these answers in a
sort of tabular form you can see there's
the same
solutions said one through nine and what
i want to do is also point out that
there's relationships between the roots
and uh you know describing them in a
more synced way will just make my easy
my working easier okay so what i'm gonna
do is i'm gonna say
look i've got one and then i've got all
of those those first four
of the ninth roots that i got by going
anti-clockwise around right so there
were four extra ones
what i'm going to do just to make things
easier to talk about is i'm just going
to give them some
greek letters that's normally how we
indicate the roots of a polynomial so
i'm going to call them alpha
beta there's gamma and i'll write in
delta
right there now when you have a look at
the other four
roots you can see that because they have
this relationship with the angles that
i've already pointed out right
you can see this negative pi on 9
matches with this
2 pi on 9. the relationship between
these two is that those
are conjugates of each other you know
you're rotating
the same way around or the same angle
around
anti-clockwise versus clockwise so
therefore
i don't have to use a new greek letter
for this i'd have to call it
epsilon i guess in this case i can say
this is alpha
bar which sort of highlights the
relationship with this earlier complex
root that we got here
and i can do the same thing for all of
these subsequent roots this will be
beta bar this will be gamma
bar and then this one will be delta bar
okay so this is what we get out of the
fact that
as i've talked about before this thing
called the complex conjugate root
theorem
when you have a polynomial like for
example
z to the nine minus 1 equals 0
that's the polynomial that gives us
these nine solutions
because all the coefficients are real
all of the roots will come in conjugate
pairs and that's exactly what we see
here alpha alpha bar
beta beta bar and so on okay
so where do i go with this well i'm now
ready to start
uh moving into part b now that i've got
a concise way to talk about all nine
of these roots so when we have a think
about this right this is where we're
going to begin
z to the nine minus one which i said was
the polynomial which gives us these
solutions
i can write it in this factorized form
because i have all nine of the roots
now just to remind you what this means
right if i said to you okay here's
here's a polynomial right
um let's say x squared give you an
example like
minus 5 x plus 6
okay so if i said that equals 0
we can factorize this and then get the
roots out of it right
did i choose some nice easy numbers i
don't know if i did i think i chose the
right disaster
let's just change that plus six uh let's
change that into a minus that'll be
that'll be more interesting okay
so here the pair of numbers that's going
to factorize this nicely will be
x minus six and x plus one
equals zero from which you could say
that the roots of this
uh quadratic would be negative one or
six
now what i'm going to do what you can
see me doing in this line is going in
reverse right
instead of saying here's the
factorization therefore here are the
roots
what i've got here is q are the roots
therefore
here is the vectorization that goes with
it you can see i have nine
linear factors there are no z squareds
or z cubes they're all just z to the
power of one
and then each one is paired with one of
the nine
roots alpha alpha bar beta beta bar
and so on okay so since z1 z2
through z and z9 are the solutions of
this polynomial z to the nine minus one
that allows me to rewrite it in this way
okay so what can i do with this well if
you have a think about this right what
i'm trying to get to if you have a look
at this result that i'm trying to prove
see see this this thing here um it's
it's got quadratic factors you see that
so instead of the linear factors that i
have here z
ah to the one z to the one and so on you
can see that
somehow i'm going to have to combine
pairs of linear factors
to give me quadratic factors so it
really is about
pairing up in a sensible way to make the
simplification
as easy as possible and you can actually
see i've already begun to do this
i haven't written these um factors in
the same order as i wrote these
these roots up here right i've paired up
intentionally
alpha with alpha bar you can see that as
my um
whoopsie does he that's very very thin
let's try and make that a little easier
to write
that's my first pair of linear factors
here
you can see it keeps going here's z
minus z bar
and so on so the reason why this is
useful
is because combining complex number with
its conjugate
allows for us to simplify a bunch of
things so to remind you of how
this works let's just consider some
general complex number
you know omega for example and then say
okay
what happens if i add these two numbers
together the
complex numbers conjugate and what
happens if i multiply these are going to
be two results that are going to be
both important to me when i actually go
and do these expansions okay
so first i'm going to say is what
happens when we add well
by definition what i'm going to get is a
plus ib
plus a minus ib right
so this is handy because my ibs are
going to cancel with
each other so in this case i would just
be left with 2a
but a more helpful way to write it in a
context in the context that we're
working with
is to say that a is the real component
of omega a random complex number so i'm
going to write that as 2
times the real component of omega all
right so far so good
what happens over here when we multiply
well
what you're getting here is the
difference of squares aren't you this is
a plus b times a sorry a plus ib
times a minus ib so you're going to get
an a squared b squared situation
except it's not a squared b squared it's
a squared
i squared b squared because the ib
is being squared there right so this is
going to be
a squared is actually the sum of squares
and the reason why this is useful to me
is because when you think about the
connection between this
and our original complex number this
this rings a bell
this looks a whole lot like pythagoras
doesn't it and that's because
this is part of our formula for finding
the modulus
of a complex number so if i multiply a
complex number
by its conjugate what i'm really getting
is
the square of the modulus okay so
this is going to be really useful when i
then say all right let's take these
results
and we're now going to think about
expanding these pairs of
linear factors which have a complex
number and it's conjugate let's go ahead
and see what actually emerges so i'm
just going to go
term by term here right i'm going to get
z squared
minus alpha bar z
there's the first expansion then i'm
going to go minus
alpha z and then i'm going to add
alpha alpha bar so far so good
i can go one step further and i can do a
bit of factorization to make the results
that i just established a bit easier to
see
so you've got your z squared out here
i'm going to subtract
and then here i'm going to factor out z
so that leaves me with an alpha
plus alpha bar this is the number plus
its conjugate that we saw
earlier and that's multiplied by z
okay so in this context i can say
i know what this these results are going
to be equal to right
i've got 2 times the real component of
whatever complex number i started with
which in this case is alpha and that's
multiplied by z
and then along the end here i have the
modulus
of uh not z but alpha
that's the particular complex number
that i'm um that i've got multiplying by
its conjugate here
that thing is being squared okay now at
this point we're almost there to
use this result um many many times i
know what alpha is alpha is just my
shorthand for
this particular one of the roots the
ninth roots of unity right
so that tells me two things number one e
to the i
two pi on nine that's just shorthand as
you recall for
polar form right um cos two pi on nine
plus i sine two pi on nine so down here
in my working
right here where i want the real
component of alpha the real component of
alpha is this it's the cos 2 pi on 9.
this is the imaginary part that i'm
going to discard
so this is really good because you can
see if i have a look at this result
i've got a z squared and i've got 2 cos
2 pi
9 z that's the the real component of z
that i've noticed here or alpha i should
say in this case
so what i can do is for this example z
minus alpha times z minus alpha bar
i can say i get z squared i've left it
on purple
z squared minus 2 cos 2 pi on 9
that's my uh my real component of alpha
and that's being multiplied by
z and because i've got these roots of
unity right
the roots of unity all lie on the unit
circle is what we noticed before so
therefore the modulus of alpha
and the modulus of beta and the modulus
of all the other of the ninth roots the
modulus is just
one so really i'm getting one squared on
the end which is
one so this is what happens when i take
these pairs of linear factors that
include these
complex conjugates in them it simplifies
out
to this and this is the term that i'm
going to have to use or this is the
expression rather i'm going to have to
use
over and over again because this is not
the only pair of linear factors i've got
i've got this pair and i've got this
pair and i've got this pair as well
okay so if i use this this result here
and i just use it repeatedly
in in this line here which i've i've
named this equation 1. so if i
take all these pairings and use this
result this is what you end up with
bam so you can see z to the 9 minus 1
that's what i started with right
z minus 1 it hasn't paired up with
anything because
1 is its own complex conjugate doesn't
have every real number is its own
complex conjugate
but then these results here if you just
if i just highlight this right
you can see this one is the first one
right here
and then as you go along the line this
one here is the same result but instead
of 2.9 it's
four pi online it's just for beta and b
to bar this is for gamma and gamma bar
this is for delta and delta bar keep all
of the roots straight